foreign
he made an honest woman of me
congratulations
thank you
what do you want
I knew it was you
not playing this game again
it's not a game Jamie be on that fancy
computer log on to the Bureau of
prison's website would you
you do have access to that
I was always the computer whiz
and you have a crack at it
a little lower get away from mine
I have done everything I need to do to
never see this world again Jamie I am
prepared
I will ruin my life today
and I swear to God I'll [__] kill you
so just sit down and let me do it
Auto Phil on the passwords
foreign
way to keep the computer system secure
have a look
if you saw him then you know it wasn't
me it's not what he said oh he's [__]
lying you saw him in the prison I would
just see him in the prison to find out
if my father was [__] involved was he
I had no idea none
he he only admitted it once I held a
[__] gun to his head and when he did
admit it why didn't you blow his head
off
why
Because deep down in here it's what you
always wanted
I'm sure he told you that he did it
because he loves you
right he loves you Jamie
and he wants the best for you and all
the things that you deserve but that's
just not the truth is it
he just wants what you want
he wants what everyone who has ever
attacked us once he wants the land
option one I tell my father he will call
the governor and he will have you both
arrested your spineless woman murdering
father
will instantly say it was your idea
you know that right he will cut an
immunity deal and he will testify
against you
you will be charged with tempted murder
times three
and we'll spend the rest of your life in
jail
which actually won't be that long
because you'll probably commit suicide
after your first rape
option two now this is a good one
I tell my husband what your father did
and he will kill him
and then tell my husband
that you had his child
cut from
and then you had me start
Ed so he can never have a family of his
own
and you
no matter where you hide you will find
you and he will tear you apart with his
bare [__] hands
would you like to know which option I
yes wait yes please please please please
please please please please
there is a third option
care to hear it
[Music]